Nate right yeah okay elevator with Seth
Rogen huh okay when was that this was
last year under what circumstances where
it was uh in Burbank and I had an
interview we just happened to be in the
same building and then our elevator
broke down okay so what what's your
first reaction I was not in a great mood
because I think I really bombed the
interview
and then he walked in and I was like is
this is this Seth Rogen I was really
like thrown off by that and then almost
instantly after he gets on it like
crashes on the next floor so we both
just kind of like we hadn't said
anything at that moment and we look at
each other and then we kind of realize
oh dang we're stuck in here now and so
that's when we started talking so I mean
like what'd you talk about what did he
say he made fun of my clothes so if this
story is true Seth Rogen finds himself
in this extreme circumstance and feels
the need to degrade the other person in
the elevator with him